as an architect i spend most of my days
behind a computer screen so it's
important to me that every element is
perfect
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the office
tour and how it's slowly progressing and
how it will progress
in the future we might as well get
straight to the point and start with the
peripherals so from the keyboard and
mouse point of view i've just
recently upgraded my keyboard to the
brand new logitech mx keys
this keyboard has been part of my kit
for about a month now and i can honestly
say
it is flawless as soon as i bought the
keyboard and took it out the box i knew
it was a premium quality product because
it was so
heavy and so well built i don't think
i've ever had
any piece of computer equipment that is
just
so well made i've it sits so well on the
desk there's no resistance against the
table so if you push it you have to push
it quite hard
for it to move which means it's always
in the perfect spot the keyboard in
itself
is almost silent which i absolutely love
personally i don't
like a mechanical keyboard especially
when you're working in an office
with somebody else because it is the
most annoying and frustrating thing in
the world
being the person next to the person with
the mechanical keyboard
mechanical keyboards are all well and
good and they're super satisfying
but i just genuinely love a good
keyboard that is ultra quiet and ultra
minimalist the one thing i love about
this logitech keyboard is the simple
fact that it's interchangeable between
operating systems
so yes i use a windows computer here but
at the same time i use a mac computer at
work
so if i ever wanted to i could easily
pick up this keyboard take it to work
and have
no problems whatsoever trying to figure
out where all the keys are now this
keyboard is also charged with usbc which
is absolutely phenomenal
i love that everything's moving to usbc
and it's slowly becoming a uniformed
cable system
now moving on to the mouse i still use
the mx2 master mouse and not the mx3
i only purchased the mx2 a couple years
ago so it's still
very new for me and it's still doing a
phenomenal job
i don't think there's enough of a
justifiable reason to swap from the two
to the three
unless something goes wrong with your
two so for the time being the mx2
is absolutely phenomenal unfortunately
it isn't usbc
it is micro usb so it is a secondary
cable of charging
whereas the mx3 is usbc so
that could be a sway point for you if
you're looking to upgrade and
stick to that one cable system i
genuinely just love this mouse for the
simple fact that it has the ever scroll
functionality
you can just sit there and scroll that
wheel and it will just continue to
scroll for pages and pages and pages
i think i tested it once and it runs for
about 15 to 20 seconds straight
depending how
much force you put into the spinning of
the wheel and even though that's not the
be-all end-all of tech
it is a really cool feature and it's
something that i do miss when i use a
different mouse that doesn't have this
feature
overall both the keyboard and the mouse
are super ergonomic they're super
comfortable
you can sit behind the keyboard for
hours and hours and use the mouse all
day long and your hands
won't get sore moving onto the screens
and probably what is the most important
part of
any computer setup and any office tour
is my two 27 asus mx279h
monitors now both of these monitors are
a little bit outdated and i'm not gonna
lie
they're not the best thing money can buy
right now in 2021
but they are still phenomenal monitors i
purchased one originally i had just a
single monitor set up but it didn't take
me very long to realize
that i needed a second monitor to
actually be able to do
my work effectively so i use a 227 inch
monitor setup
right now in 2021 i am looking for a
potential swap out for 49-inch samsung
monitor
but i'm just not sold on it yet so i'm
sticking with the 27s for the time being
the two monitors behind me are full hd
with ips eye protection and even though
they're full hd
you wouldn't think that they are full hd
i've used monitors
that claim to be full hd and they're
very blurry and pixelated whereas these
two monitors are still very crystal
clear and very sharp
the monitors don't have an excessive
amount of ports at the back they are
predominantly hdmi
and dvi cables there is sound input as
well but there is nothing special there
is no usbc in these monitors there's no
usb-a
they are just your standard
run-of-the-mill monitors from going back
a few years now
as you can see the monitors are backlit
with leds that are purchased
off ebay i genuinely just got the
cheapest nastiest leds i could find
when i started this youtube channel to
see if it would go anywhere
two years down the track we're slowly
growing this community so thank you so
much for being
here with me along this journey if
you're new smash that subscribe button
down below
because every new subscriber encourages
me to keep making these videos and
publishing content for you guys
the leds are very simple and very basic
it would be my personal preference to
run them in a cool white color
however the white setting on these leds
is a little bit blue tingy and doesn't
look very good
so that's why i keep them on the blue
light itself
with the contrasting orange lamp in the
corner the leds themselves are
incredibly messy they're incredibly ugly
so i'm very glad that they're stuck
behind the screens and
against the wall because there is no way
you'd want to use these
leds anywhere that are visible i think
leds
are slowly phasing their way out but
because this is a rental house
i can't do much this space i can't paint
i can't put wallpaper up
i don't want to put sound panels up
because it will destroy the walls when i
leave
so i'm just trying to absolutely make
the best space by using color and
creative decoration
more so than actually changing the
environment because if i had it my way
trust me this space would be a lot
different what you'll notice is unlike
many other desk tours there is no
speakers on this desk because i
personally don't require it
i think the monitors themselves have a
phenomenal sound and for those moments
that the monitors aren't good enough or
i don't want that
blasting sound directly in my face
there's a small google home mini that i
genuinely just use
for playing ambient music throughout the
day the google home mini
is fantastic it's such a small powerful
little device i have a number of them
spread out throughout the home
and they do interconnect when you want
them to so overall for like 50 bucks or
whatever they are
they are phenomenal i don't personally
think i need a google home max or
anything in this space
everybody's talking about how you need
the biggest and best and loudest
speakers but
genuinely i don't think they're required
i think when you're working as an
architect and when you're working
in any professional environment you need
to be able to concentrate and focus
and if you have blaring music at least
in my opinion in my instance
it doesn't really help you concentrate
so having a small speaker that provides
that
audio but isn't overpowering at the same
time is
absolutely perfect for this space the
speaker sits on a very industrial
looking
lamp that was purchased from kmart for
about 20 bucks it isn't very fancy
it isn't very special but it does
exactly what i originally intended it to
do
so the purpose of that lamp was to
create an orange backfill
on this illuminated background so that
the blue and the orange complemented the
tones
i love the fact that this globe has the
wires and the electricity running
through it
and heating it up it makes such a cool
little effect
i think there's there's a number of
things i could have put in this space
but
i'm happy with that lamp and it does
actually get used at night time
when i just need a little bit of
additional lighting and the lights in
the room just starting off
for a decoration piece on the side there
is a small little fake plant and also
a candle that was also purchased from
kmart just to really tie the scene in
i do really love nature and i do love
indoor plants but unfortunately this
room doesn't really receive too much
attention and it doesn't receive too
much sunlight
so having a plan in here would quickly
and rapidly die because it's the back of
the house it's on the south side
and it would just get very cold and get
no light so
unfortunately i've had to settle for an
artificial plant in this space
nonetheless it still does look pretty
good for i think i paid
12 for it so it isn't an expensive
addition
but it is something that just ties the
space back in now what about the desk
the desk is obviously pivotal
i haven't purchased a sit-stand desk in
this situation for a very simple reason
this desk behind me is your standard
ikea limnon
desk with a couple cheap legs from ikea
as well
it was custom trimmed by my dad who i'm
very thankful who did the job for me
to fit this room perfectly if you notice
the little
trim in between the two desks there is
two side-by-side limnon desks
perfectly cut for this space so if you
take out one of the desks it is
millimeter perfect which means if i was
to go ahead and put in a sit-stand desk
either the desk would have to reduce in
size or it would be constantly scraping
the walls and damaging the walls
i have a sit stand desk at work i don't
use it often enough to be able to
justify bringing it into the home
so i think that having just a really
good
really wide and really long desk is
beneficial in more ways than having a
sit stand desk above the desk i have my
degrees in architecture because
well what else do you do with a very
expensive piece of paper
on my right hand side i also have one of
my largest achievements to date wire
watches
which was a company i launched back in
2016.
it was phenomenal and pivotal in my
career and taught me so much
so i will always treasure that piece
underneath the desk i have two
very important things that get used
non-stop
obviously the first is my custom built
gaming pc
i custom built this myself a couple
years back and it was built to be
an architectural rendering machine it
had all the latest and greatest tech in
there at the time
but it's slowly become outdated and it's
slowly requiring more and more upgrades
so originally it was an i7 processor
with 16 gigs of ram
and one terabyte of storage that storage
wasn't ssd so i slowly started upgrading
the ssd storage
to one terabyte two terabytes and slowly
working my way up
i also recently upgraded the sound card
as well as the graphics cards on
the device to be able to keep up with
the growing demand
of architectural requirements in all
software at the current time i still
think this computer
isn't powerful enough to do what i
actually want to do
it's still very laggy it's still very
glitchy especially when editing 4k video
and trying to do multiple overlays in
premiere pro
which shouldn't actually be that hard
considering it's able to render
8k images of incredible scenes
relatively quickly but it wasn't custom
built for video editing
it was custom built for architecture if
you follow me on instagram there's a
link down below you'll see some of the
renders and some of the work that i do
produce as an architect
underneath the desk there is also a very
important very basic piece of kit and
that is the shredder
i won't go into any detail with that it
is a basic shadow from officeworks i
think i paid 100 bucks for it
but you have to destroy any private
documentation properly and securely so
that's why the shredder is down there it
is kind of ugly
kind of in an awkward spot but it's
behind the desk it's under the desk it
doesn't really matter too much
so i'm happy with the spot and it works
phenomenally well the last piece in this
office tour is the chair that i'm
sitting on
this chair i purchased many years ago
when i was still in university and it
was the first chair i bought
as an architecture student and i'm
reluctant to get rid of it
it's worn it's dirty it's not the best
chair in the world anymore
but it's still somewhat comfortable and
i just genuinely love it
i think i paid an absurd amount of money
for it it was something like 400
but it was the only grey chair at that
time i could find
and it's still one of the only grey
chairs that you can buy so i don't think
i'll be giving away this chair anytime
soon i'll probably get it cleaned very
shortly
and i'll continue to use it every day it
is super comfortable
it's perfectly adjustable and it's
nothing special nothing fancy
but it does the job really well and it
ties into this space
perfectly i think no matter what space
it goes into a nice grey chair in any
environment
will always work really really well
anyway that's my entire office guys i
hope you enjoyed the office tour
i hope you got some inspiration from it
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe
down below or leave a comment if you
want to know more if you're new to the
channel i post a video every single
monday so as always
i'll see you then